apparently you just don't stop winning
okay i guess so i guess so it's yeah
last year i was completely alone when we
won so it's nice at least to be able to
look at your face and body is it fair to
say the universe gave you great material
for this past year for the past couple
of years
i guess you could say that i mean i
really wouldn't complain if the universe
gave us less you know on a human level
or even on a comedic level it's it's it
is nice to be writing jokes this year
rather than last year last year
occasionally we're writing from the
point of abject despair
your team is here they all have what
does it mean also to be able to
celebrate with them i mean
quite a lot because
i haven't been with them so this is just
like a handful of our staff um i was
hoping they'd all be here but of course
that can't happen uh but we have been so
isolated the last year and a half it is
just amazing to be in the same physical
space with them for at least one night
okay so our separate ways again so now
that you're with them will you go out
and celebrate with those guys tonight
will you take them out i mean i i was
really hoping to go to bed
um
and also i don't know if you know your
boss going out with you doesn't
generally make the night better so i
think i might do the kind thing and let
them go and party on their own rather
than be the debbie downer for the whole
crew
also how much longer can you do it
because listen it's been a heck of a run
but it's also i mean
it's a
you seem to be looking into my aging
facing in are you you might want to just
you want i'd say two more years max and
then just think about stopping no i know
that you know after a while it it it
gets to be a lot there's no way to say
it nicely just come out and say it hard
listen i don't know if your body
can keep doing this for long it's a good
it's a fair question i don't know i
don't have uh a conan 30 years in me
that's for sure
also the box last year you had the box
that you could open up and it had the
little prize and the emmy came out was
that better or this better well i will
say about that at the time amazing
because it's an it's an exploding box
with glitter coming out of it
here's the thing when you're alone in a
room and then the cameras come off uh
the cameras turn off i was i just had to
clean that room up and i cannot tell you
how long it took on my hands and knees
picking up glitter thinking this is not
the glamorous life of the enemies that i
think i was promised so you spent the
evening cleaning up glitter i spent the
evening cleaning up a box of exploding
glitter i felt like mariah carey's
assistant
hey congratulations on a job well done
again you're fantastic and what you've
done you can tell by how often it goes
viral that it is commentary that the
world needs oh thanks so much i'm really
glad people still want to watch it and
it's really nice to see you again it's
great to see you and are you are you
okay with us americans and all the
things that we're doing here i'm well
here's the thing i'm an american citizen
now oh yes you're one of us now say us
americans it's all my fault too in fact
it's probably my fault because if you go
back in history
britain kind of is the root cause of so
many of the world's problems right now
so it's
i mean really
you guys just dodging in the background
yeah yeah that's fair yeah i mean just
historically you really did set us up to
fail